chers amis
cette année encore nos universités de
rentrée ont été marquées par le soleil
par la hauteur de vue le partage et la
convivialité
au cours de ces trois jours nous avons
appris débattus autour de nombreuses
personnalités de notre mouvement et
d'ailleurs que je souhaite remercier de
leur présence ce sont plus de 1000
personnes que nous avons accueillies 70
ateliers que nous avons organisés grâce
au travail acharné d'une petite équipe
que je souhaite remercier en votre nom
en espérant n'oublier personne
l'équipe du siège d'abord
Anne Caroline Gina Fabien Delphine
Virginie Martin François Olivia
Philomena Cécile Florian Emma souria
Vincent et Jean-Baptiste on peut les
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
accompagné par des bénévoles dont je
salue la fidélité
Jean-Baptiste dans la salle
Jacques Laurent devant moi nos
conducteurs Charlie Morgane Sylvain
Paul-Jean Alicia Balthazar Alan Héloïse
Anaïs Jérémy Emmanuel Céline Jérémy
Sébastien Alexandra et Mathieu merci à
vous tous
[Applaudissements]
et puis je voudrais dire un mot pour
ceux qui nous accompagnent depuis tant
d'années qui veille à que tout se passe
bien les magiciens du son et de la
technique Gilou et toute son équipe
merci à vous
et puis le personnel de ce site qui
depuis 10 ans nous font sortir nous font
sentir comme si nous étions à la maison
et oui 10 ans 10 ans déjà
on a vu de jolies images depuis 10 ans
nous sommes ici à Guidel c'est en 2012
pour la première fois que nous avons
organisé notre université de rentrée
alors nous sommes particulièrement
nombreux ce matin et parmi vous nombreux
étaient celles et ceux qui étaient là il
y a 10 ans
dans des moments parfois difficiles pour
notre mouvement mais toujours plein
d'espoir et sans regret
il nous a parfois fallu renoncer à tout
pour ne pas sacrifier l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est ce que nous sommes
humanistes l'essentiel c'est ce à quoi
nous croyons le rassemblement au service
de l'intérêt général
François Bayrou a ouvert ses universités
de rentrée en rappelant que nous étions
réunis soudés et en ordre de marche
cela n'aurait pas été possible sans ces
dix années sans vous qui vous êtes
battus pour continuer à porter la voix
les idées et les valeurs de notre
mouvement vous qui êtes là et celles et
ceux qui nous manquent
si nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui autour
de François Bayrou de nos ministres
Marc Geneviève Sarah Jean-Noël je veux
vous dire combien nous sommes heureux et
fiers que vous représentiez notre
mouvement gouvernement avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires
[Applaudissements]
avec l'ensemble des parlementaires les
députés auprès de Jean-Paul les
sénateurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices autour de
Jean-Marie van lorenberg
[Applaudissements]
les députés européens autour de
Marie-Pierre Vedène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si nous sommes réunis c'est parce que
collectivement nous n'avons pas des
billets de notre route
cette solidité dans les convictions
cette authenticité dans l'engagement
cette constance dans les valeurs que
nous défendons irrigue notre manière
d'être et de faire de la politique oui
nous sommes exigeants oui nous sommes
déterminés dans l'action c'est le fruit
de notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
et face à la triple crise que nous
traversons exigence et détermination me
semble être ce dont nous avons besoin
crise géopolitique bien sûr le 24
février dernier l'invasion russe du
territoire ukrainien fut un tremblement
de terre depuis plus de six mois le
retour de la guerre sur le sol européen
fait peser des menaces sur notre
sécurité Pelée collective mais également
pour la souveraineté alimentaire et
énergétique de notre continent et
au-delà
la scène internationale est marquée par
la remise en cause de l'intégrité des
frontières l'augmentation de la menace
nucléaire l'exacerbation des tensions en
Indo-Pacifique notamment et à Taïwan
l'émergence de nouveautés
un monde en plein bouleversement ou
l'aspiration à la liberté des peuples et
je pense particulièrement aux femmes
iraniennes constituent une leçon de
courage et une lueur d'espoir
le défi climatique ensuite pour ma
génération le climat a toujours été une
préoccupation centrale désormais
l'urgence climatique et partagée par
tous l'impérieuse nécessité de réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
n'a d'égal que notre détermination agir
plus fort plus vite en veillant toujours
à protéger les premières victimes du
dérèglement climatique
au sein de nos frontières comme à
l'extérieur
opposé fin du monde et fin du mois n'a
aucun sens car ce sont toujours les plus
fragiles qui sont les premières victimes
du dérèglement des climats
[Applaudissements]
et nous avons besoin de produire pour
financer notre modèle social au cœur de
notre pacte social produire différemment
mais sans tomber dans la décroissance
l'autre fondement du modèle avec
l'écologie c'est la démocratie nous
n'avons eu de cesse d'alerter sur la
nécessité de revivifier notre démocratie
retissez le lien distendu entre nos
concitoyens et leurs élus redonner du
sens au vote les difficultés économiques
et sociales exacerbes les tensions sur
le plan démocratique nourrissent la
défiance et la montée des populismes de
tout bord en France comme ailleurs pour
la première fois de son histoire
l'extrême droite est au pouvoir en Suède
la Suède qui prendra la présidence du
Conseil de l'Union européenne en janvier
prochain les dictons partout et je veux
dire à nos amis italiens qui votent
aujourd'hui que l'extrême droite n'a
jamais et ne sera jamais la solution au
mot de nos démocraties
[Applaudissements]
les enjeux sont immenses ce dont il
s'agit c'est de la cohésion de nos
sociétés fondées sur une vision partagée
de l'avenir pour y répondre nous devons
écouter entendre agir agir selon une
vision ambitieuse pour notre pays pour
l'Europe et dans le monde il faudra du
courage nous n'en manquons pas et j'ai
confiance dans notre capacité collective
à œuvrer et à relever tous les défis qui
se dressent devant nous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]